[Music]  this is a very serious question okay  from this day forward you will become  spells weapons in a global struggle for  power you'll be trained in psychological  manipulation when we are finished with  you the person you were in no longer  exists which Kardashian  do you think would make the best sparrow  well Kim and I'm not just saying that  cuz I want because I want to talk about  Kim Kardashian no she is she could  honestly be recruited by the army yeah I  used to be like the go-to spy that  everyone would call and try to get info  on their boyfriends or husbands or  whatever she was like talking about how  she was like hacking phones I like took  my phone I'm just kind of scooted it  backwards let's try and break into his  voicemail I have so many tricks up my  sleeve no one wants to mess with me she  reads people she knows how to shut  people down she could totally be a  sparrow you have a gift you know how to  survive  this is what you were meant to do  you